this satellite image from the port of
sevastopol in crimea on may 21st shows
trucks lined up near a russian ship
loading stolen ukrainian grain
a russian soldier who drove one of the
trucks around this time explained to the
details of the smuggling operations
[Music]
in may the u.s state department sent
cables to several countries stating that
three russian ships the matros poseinic
metros koshka and mikhail
were suspected of transporting stolen
ukrainian grain according to a senior
european diplomat who viewed the cable
russian officials have rejected such
accusations
but we found these three ships are part
of a smuggling route that russia has
been developing to transport stolen
grain out of newly occupied areas of
ukraine and into russian allied
countries in the middle east
we analyzed telegram posts satellite
imagery and ship transponder data
reviewed documents and interviewed
people involved in this illicit trade to
reveal a 1500 mile smuggling route that
gives us a window into the broader
network russia has quietly assembled to
transport hundreds of thousands of
metric tons of grain out of ukraine
russia has done this all while
obstructing ukraine from exporting its
own grain and seeds up to 70 million
metric tons per year a large slice of
the world's supply much of which flows
to the developing world
in recent weeks ukraine said turkey
detained a russian ship with stolen
ukrainian grain while accusations of war
crimes and fears of a global food crisis
have mounted
the main route we uncovered starts in
southeastern ukraine
in the occupied city of kamianka
neprovska at one of the largest grain
storage facilities in the region run by
a company we aren't naming we found
evidence of dozens of russian-controlled
trucks transporting grain from this
facility since early may
the driver we interviewed a soldier in
the russian army who said he doesn't
want to fight in the war told us that in
late may a russian colonel ordered him
to pick up a load of grain at this
facility our many trucks sitting trucks
i had a wider camera truck
when i come in the morning
may 21 22 corner put trucks up online
we took weekend travels
each truck can move around 10 to 50
metric tons of grain in a single hall
in photos from the facility that appear
to be from early may reviewed by the
journal
we see trucks covered with tarps
z's on the front
and concealed license plates
the russian driver we interviewed
confirmed that he and the other drivers
in his caravan drove similar trucks
less than two kilometers from the depot
this photo posted to facebook on may
19th by a local resident shows trucks
with the same characteristics
tarps and no license plates headed away
from the grain storage facility
in satellite imagery from june 11th we
see similar vehicles near the grain
silos
three days later we can see a line of
them outside the facility and a few more
in the parking lot as well
by june 22nd there are over 30 of these
trucks visible
the russian driver said his convoy of
trucks with stolen grain drove to crimea
on may 21st or 22nd
i hear on radio we go to
many hours
but
we also found evidence that another
major grain storage facility in the
region was taken over by the russian
military seen here on march 26th
a satellite image from the same date and
location shows what appear to be those
same tanks
this letter from an official installed
by russian forces
informed the company that their property
was being seized
after the takeover the company said they
were still able to track their stolen
trucks using gps which were loaded with
grain and also driven into crimea
at one of the facilities where grain was
taken we can see that a z a russian
pro-war symbol has been marked on the
roof
in addition to using truck drivers from
the russian army drivers for these
routes are also hired through messages
posted to social media like this may 24
telegram post by a logistics operator
advertising nearly 20 truck routes to
transport grain mostly from newly
occupied russian territory in ukraine to
crimea this is a route similar to the
one our russian driver took and offers
about 30 us dollars per ton in pay
ukraine's access to export routes out of
crimea has been largely cut off since
the 2014 annexation
now in videos published over the last
several weeks we see long lines of
trucks heading south into the region
many resemble the trucks at the grain
depot in kamianka neprovska and fit the
description given by people involved in
the trade
once in crimea the russian driver said
he and the other drivers dropped off the
trucks at the sevastopol port where many
tons of grain were unloaded to conveyor
belts and then moved to waiting ships
[Music]
in satellite imagery from sevastopol on
may 19th 21st and 23rd we can see three
different ships loading grain the same
ones listed in the state department
cable
the matros posenich matras koshka and
mikhail nanashev were all newly
registered in the months before the war
to a russian state-owned company called
crane marine contractor llc according to
a ship company database
satellite images paired with ship
tracking data from marine traffic show
these same ships running regular routes
from crimea to the eastern mediterranean
since at least late march
often shutting off their transponders as
they approach ports likely in an effort
to conceal their locations
for example the matros posinic
disappears from tracking data near
istanbul on may 17th
we then see it being loaded with what
looks like grain at the port in
sevastopol two days later
the ship's transponder restarts again on
may 21st after it departs sepastopol
over the next two days marine traffic
data shows it passes through the boss
for a straight
which we can see in photos of the
waterway from may 22nd
the ship's tracking is then turned off
again as it nears its destination with
its last location reported on may 25th
in the mediterranean sea between turkey
and cyprus
soon after in latakia syria satellite
imagery shows the ship docked and its
contents being unloaded
commodity brokers involved in the
network say the grain was imported by a
syrian state-run grain company
after similar journeys from sevastopol
to the eastern mediterranean the mikael
nanashev docks in turkey
the mattress koshka goes dark for over a
week
but reappears as it heads back towards
the black sea
crane marine contractor llc and syria's
ministry of foreign affairs did not
respond to requests for comment
the russian embassy in washington dc
referred us to a prior statement made by
the russian ambassador to the u.s in
which he rejected accusations of grain
theft
the frequency of thefts at grain
facilities combined with the repetition
of these vessels journeys and the sheer
number of trucks traveling into crimea
shows that russia is working quickly to
institutionalize its grain smuggling
network in our last conversation with a
russian truck driver in late june he
said he was waiting to receive orders
for his next truck
route i think i drive again
[Music]